hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
stoicism as a philosophy and as a way of
life is an ascetic philosophy that means
that it involves as we've got translated
here some sort of training some s Cesis
another way of thinking about it is
disciplining it's disciplining of the
self when we talk about somebody
engaging in askesis or being an ascetic
very often people will think about you
know monastic orders or self-denial or
things along those lines and there is
something to that but the point of doing
anything ascetic at least for the
philosophers is to give oneself to a
better condition and that's part of what
the stoic philosophy is doing it is a a
philosophical position that holds that
human beings should live the most
rational life possible whether the the
starts really understood that our
rationality is not something that works
you know sort of like a computer or a
robot where we just put the right
information in and suddenly everything
now correct on the other side instead
it's a matter of training of retraining
ourselves so that we can become you know
happier freer so that things can work
out better for us because we have set
ourselves up for that so there is a
chapter where Epictetus talks explicitly
about what training involves there are
there are many discussions of training
throughout the discourses but this one
is particularly useful so the goal of
stoic training is to be able to actually
live out the good life as stoic
philosophy understands it so what is
that like you know he gives you one
gloss and here he says you know the goal
is to act without hindrance and choice
and in aversion it's also you know we
could say to bring our Faculty of choice
in accordance with or to harmonize it
with nature it's also to people to live
out our relations to other people as we
would like to and as we recognize we
want to in ways that are good there's
many different ways to frame exactly
what what stoic philosophy understands
is the good life because it's you know
this fairly complex conception right the
goal though is to actually live that out
not just to talk about it as Epictetus
points out to us it's not about to read
stoic philosophy we have to actually put
it into practice and not just put it
into practice by applying it but by
doing that over and over again and
learning well is this working for me
what are the obstacles all those are
parts of training so he begins by
talking about a training desire and
aversion away from externals we might
think about this in terms of training
training ourselves centering training on
what's
most essential rather than on what is
just for show or innocence well he talks
at the beginning of this chapter about
not taking our training and things that
are unnatural or fantastic because if
we're doing that we're pretending that
we're philosophers but we're actually
charlatans he says it's a hard thing
also to walk a tightrope not merely hard
but dangerous too
should we for this reason to practice
walking a tightrope or setting up a
polymer throwing arms around statues
which is what the Saints did and
Epictetus says no we don't need to do
that what we need to focus on is what's
really on the course know what
philosophy training the Faculty of
choice training our rational faculty
overcoming the you know the habits that
we have that the screw us up working
through the conflicts that we find in
our behavior and our declarations about
what we believe and what we value doing
all those sorts of things we don't need
to do things that are just showing those
are externals those are not going to
help us a little bit later he says we
you know we want to train our desire and
our aversion so that they focus on
things that are actually in our power so
for example we can't avoid dying
sometime sooner or later every one of us
is going to die that is unavoidable we
have a natural aversion to it our
culture tends to intensify that by
preaching that death is a terrible thing
as it has every human culture and if we
follow that up we're going to be unhappy
because soon you know we think am I
gonna die this year am I gonna die next
year how can I avoid it I can't avoid it
oh woe is me
right and we're not going to be made
happy by that instead we can we can
train our aversion to focus on our own
thought processes and our own emotions
we can say man I don't want to feel that
way and when we do that as soon as we
say I don't want to feel
way rather than I don't want that to
happen to me we are we are focusing on
what's actually within the realm of our
Faculty of choice so we want to retrain
the desires and the inversions away from
things that we don't have control over
external things and towards our own
valuations our own processes as he says
it's impossible without great and
constant training to secure that our
desire fail not to attain and our
aversion fall not into what it what it
would avoid so you should be assured if
you allow allow your training to turn
outwards towards the things that are not
in the realm of your Faculty of choice
you will neither have your desire
successful entertaining what it would
Noorie or diverting successful and
avoiding what it would so we want to
start accumulating successes you might
say by focusing on the things that the
action do you have some control over and
training our desire and our version on
those things he also talks about the
need to build new habits why new habits
because we already have old habits in
place it's not enough just to try to
wipe out old habits
as a matter of fact it's it's almost
impossible to just wipe out a habit and
replace it with nothing we have to
replace old habits with new habits habit
plays an incredibly important role in
any sort of training whether it be
technical training or some sort of
artistic training all organ training
firfer the the you know great event that
is life so he says since Hamlet is a
powerful influence when we have accustom
ourselves to employ desire and aversion
only on those externals we have to set a
contrary habit to counteract this habit
where the very slippery nature of
appearances in play there are we must
set our training as a counteracting
force so what we have to create new
habits if we find ourselves being the
kind of person who is inclined towards
eating too much not have
self-control when I comes to food then
they have to figure out what new habit
am I going to put in place that could
actually counteract that and so this
leads us to the next bits of advice
eating is he says when you're in
training you don't have to as the
proverb goes boil the ocean focus on the
things that you can actually attain
success in and the things you know are
beyond you at this point get away from
them don't even get involved with those
sorts of things so for example if you
know that you cannot deal with your your
anger problems then you probably when
you feel yourself getting angry need to
go somewhere else and not engage that's
not for you yet to try to work on that
if you find that you cannot control your
desires for for food or for drink or
things like that then you probably need
to remove that as a sort of occasion and
then and you know maybe leave that up to
somebody else certainly don't go out to
Dunkin Donuts or you know the ice cream
shop or things put those temptations in
your way right and we could go on and on
and on about that if you find that
you're having a very difficult time
dealing with sexual attraction then try
to minimize the occasions on which
that's going to become an issue you know
so that's a very that's a very good bit
of advice right there so though to you
know put off certain things you don't
have to try to work on every single part
of yourself in training at the same time
because that's that's sort of a recipe
for failure now the things that you do
need to work upon that's something that
you have to think about and it gets some
great examples here
he says I'm inclined to pleasure I'm
hoping to take myself to the opposite
side of the rolling ship and that be
measure so as to train myself so what
you do is you determine what things you
need to work on and that you think you
can actually make some success with at
least at the time and you place yourself
at the other extreme from those things
so you know you find yourself spending
far too much time on the internet and
checking your email every twenty minutes
just to see whether something came in or
checking your Facebook maybe what you
need is to say I'm going to limit myself
to only 30 minutes a day then that might
be an extreme warning quit cold-turkey
that's another extreme here's some other
examples I'm inclined to avoid hard work
well if you want to fix that strain and
exercise your sense impressions to this
end so that your aversion from
everything of this kind shell sees the
things that you have out-of-control
desires or out of the control of
versions towards they will get better if
you put yourself at the other extreme
for a while and you use your Faculty of
choice which you do have to keep pushing
and pushing and pushing eventually
you'll find that those desires no longer
are quite so strong you see this with
you know trying to overcome addictions
to for example tobacco very tough one
right there you know but if you manage
to go for my experience of that is you
know the first three four days were
pretty horrible and once you got past
that X adept you know when I would see
people smoking on TV or go to a bar or
people are smoking or you know have a
cup of coffee and think my cigarette
would be very good right now which is I
have control over right the the desire
would would begin to cease and and the
same thing works for many other things
as well so he goes on and he says
different people are going to have to
practice particularly
to meet different things every one of us
has to figure out well where are my
weaknesses where are the things that
have that I feel have control over me
even though I should have control over
them and then what am I going to use the
element of control that I do have to
counteract that to to oppose to that so
that's a key part of this training
desire and aversion now there are two
other fields that Epictetus thinks need
to be studied as well and become part of
this training I've done another video
about the three fields so you can you
can check that out it's another core
concept video and I just want to mention
these the other two fields of study you
have to do with choice and choosing
against or refusal and with the scent
and the area of choice also includes our
duties what what it is that we ought to
do our obligations set includes all
sorts of epistemological or logical
issues how do we figure out whether
we're getting things right or not those
are things that we also have to do
training on epictetus is more talking
about this first part because he thinks
that that one is where do you need to
start that you can't immediately jump
into studying you know syllogisms and
you know arguments and analysing them
until you've actually got a good
foundation set for yourself with this
other stuff there's one other thing that
he says and it's not in that one it's
actually in chapter 15 where he
should be 315 over here so it's very
important that you think through what
you're committing to if you want to be
successful you cannot just snap your
fingers and start out you want to
actually think this through in a
methodical way
that's consider which of the things you
purposed at the start you've achieved in
which you have not likewise how it gives
you pleasure to recall some of them in
pain or call others and if possible
recover also those things which is
slipped out of your grasp what follows
from from this well we have to think
through whether we can actually bring a
bring about all of these sorts of things
and we're much more likely to be
successful with it if we don't just
immediately you know get enthusiastic
about it and jumped into it just like
people do with diets or exercise
programs or self-help books or you know
whatever other cause causes they think
they're gonna make their life meaningful
and instead you know almost put it down
on paper and think it up probably with
the help of another person as well
figuring out well what do I actually
need it to work out what are my habits
that I'm troubled by what are the things
that I probably need to avoid the
occasions for the temptations that are
likely to drug in one of the things that
I can make some progress on at this time
and how am I going to do that that is
all part of training and the goal
ultimately for the stoic is to not need
a teacher to be able to do that but to
be able to do continue this on your own
but that may not be something that the
person beginning in training can do any
more than somebody could just grab a
book and suddenly learn martial arts
by studying pictures rather than having
an instructor or you know somebody
learning music an B the same way in any
case you see just how much goes into the
stoic notion of training or discipline
as cases